it's a coast-to-coast crime wave brought
to you by democrats weak and completely
irresponsible crime policies a smash and
grab gang striking yet again in
california this time knocking off a
jewelry store and as for the thieves who
have been busted for storming other
places well the lapd announcing 14
suspects have been set free the police
chief blasting no bail policies
all the suspects taken into custody are
out of custody
either as a result of one juvenile or
the others as a result of bailing out or
no bail zero bail uh criteria the risk
of covid to those that are in custody
the court system and installed this zero
bail system as a mean of safeguard but
as we evolve through this there's
elements of
the criminal elements that are
recognizing that
condition and are capitalizing on it
in new york city a suspected gang member
with a long wrap sheet going on a
stabbing spray knifing a columbia
student who bled to death and then
wounding a tourist
bank of america is telling its employees
to dress down to avoid getting targeted
on the street while the city gets rocked
by a crime wave
so what does the white house plan to do
about all this jen saki trying to clean
up her bone-headed comments yesterday
blaming the crime on kobet watch
i think a root cause in a lot of
communities is the pandemic yes what
should have added yesterday but i
learned afterwards is that
the justice department the fbi and the
federal law enforcement have been in
touch in contact with jurisdictions
where we have seen
this high level of retail theft on top
of that the department of justice
announced last week that san francisco
where a number of high-profile retail
thefts have happened will get money to
hire 50 more police officers through the
cops program
i don't know is that going to cut it
well the thing is
adding 50 police officers fine that
might be great for a day but then if the
career criminals
get back on the street the day after
they are arrested and they're just let
go because of these new policies then it
doesn't make much sense and i think that
it would be the white house i think
would be in a position to be able to say
what's happening at the local level is
wrong but they won't
because all this goes back to all the
big funders
from the beginning and you know michael
bloomberg also was was a part of this
and trying to get more progressive
district attorneys in this in the
country that has happened and apparently
has worked i think the white house ought
to ban a phrase root causes
they have they have so many root cause
issues that they're not actually
addressing they're the root cause and
the thing is like they have jobs numbers
today and it's almost like the career
criminals
their jobs are like secure
because you're not ever going to get
put in jail and made to stay there
um
if i were at the white house i would
definitely say we should change this up
immediately one on the merits it's
necessary because of what's happening
but two because jessica's made some
great points this week about you can't
tell people that what they are seeing
with their own eyes isn't happening
because that's the surest way to make
sure that you are going to fail in
elections and then you can't get any of
your policies done do you have any more
great points i think so you might not
think so but maybe dana well um so there
are three key players that i see here so
the police chiefs the da's and the
mayors
and you're hearing more out of the
police chiefs and the mayors about this
problem eric adams went down
to the biden white house for a meeting
that was all police chiefs and mayors
he's taking a very tough on crime stance
we'll see what happens when he gets
inaugurated
but that was obviously part of his
platform for winning so if we get them
in sync and that means that those two
groups the police chiefs and the mayors
going to the da's and saying in practice
this is not working i understand we're
all progressives here because most of
the mayors are also progressive like the
da's but this is what's happening on the
streets and if we don't get all on the
same page funding is going to be cut
we're also going to lose continue to
lose tax dollars because people are
going to move out of these cities
they're not going to become empty um so
bringing that together which is
something that bloomberg worked on
really hard when he created this mayoral
task force that was a nationwide project
um and was actually quite effective is
something that i think is going to
underpin a change here and then the
white house will be able to speak more
cogently about what they're doing to try
to help but don't you also have to kick
down doors at the city council level
because it was the radical city council
members that put all these policies in
place you're going through my notes did
i'm sorry
no no i was thinking that when jessica
was saying that this actually is a
statewide level because in new york the
bail reform was at the state level also
something here in new york discovery
reform which led to fewer witnesses
coming forward because the the defense
teams were um basically given the uh
personal information of witnesses
and so it discouraged witnesses from
comments crazy the uh city council here
in new york city also passed a few years
ago like three years ago the right to
know act which forces the cops to inform
suspects that oh we're
you can tell us not to search you it
puts it puts the cops in the role of
being legal counsel to criminals so
there there are myriad problems it will
take years to be undone if they can be
undone at all but i'll tell you one
thing that would help if bank of america
they're telling their employees quietly
up maybe don't wear your wedding ring or
your engagement ring to work you they're
essentially telling their employees
you're in danger if you come to work
here yeah one night so i just work from
home
or why not move your damn jobs to
somewhere that's more hospitable you
start moving your tax base out of new
york city the building's right down the
street you want to know who's going to
sit up and take notice it's the city
council and it's the state government
that's what they ought to do they're
already in charlotte move them on out
nobody wants to live here anyway it's a
hellhole gutfeld doesn't have to worry
about looking too nice when he leaves
the building what is that supposed to
you look at yourself i what what what's
wrong you don't look like you're flossed
out gut fell look you got a black
sweater where is this going you know
does anybody know no one shouldn't just
let him go you know
the the root cause of crime is
progressivism it is the
misunderstanding of incent incentives
they are incentivizing crime by with no
bail and all of these measures that's
why you have the criminals we are
allowing the media the white house to
redefine crime as like a weather pattern
like you know you go out there
be sure and bundle up dress like a hobo
right because there's a 70 percent
chance of smash and grab 30 chance of
felonious assault so it's up to you and
it's out of your hands
uh i am so i feel so hopeless about this
because it's been going on for quite a
while that i am thinking about joining
the dark side why bother being a
law-abiding citizen and pay all these
taxes and go shopping when you can just
smash and grab i mean why am i why am i
going to amazon online when i live
around the corner from the store i could
just totally smash some windows take
some just just join if you can't beat
them join them there should be an app
for solitary people like me who can meet
up with other solitary looters because
that's my problem i don't know like i
don't have a lot of friends i don't have
a mob that can like come with me while i
go trash other people's private property
so maybe we could do it we could do an
app for that the bottom line here is we
are we've redefined law and order as
systemically racist so anytime you
enforce the law you're going to be
called a racist which is the most
effective method for undermining society
we're watching society implode
i feel absolutely hopeless that kid that
columbia kid was murdered was murdered
by a guy that's been in and out of jail
i mean maybe his parents have some
influence maybe with the with the home
invasion in beverly hills will that wake
up people that uh you know a music
legend murdered right while her while
her husband was sleeping or her husband
was sleeping she went she was murdered
why how doesn't this wake pelosi up
don't some of these people travel in the
same circles well i mean it shouldn't
have to happen that way that's the point
yeah but you know what it's it's not
until hell comes to their house right
well they wake up well it's coming
pretty close yeah hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else